it's my great pleasure to introduce our
distinguished guests for today the
award-winning graphic novelist
cartoonist writer and educator gene Luen
yang so before we begin I just have a
couple of very quick announcements I
want to first ask that everyone turn off
their cell phones and probably refrain
from taking photographs all right I
guess if you must take photographs it's
probably okay as long as no flash yeah
he's very easygoing but the other really
important announcement actually and
everyone needs to pay attention is that
the gallery actually is going to close
pretty soon so I hope no one left
anything in the lockers out there
because you're not going to be able to
access the lobby once the program is
over so we're gonna be asked to exit out
the left on to York Street so you
definitely will not be able to go back
into the lobby it's gonna pause for a
second does anybody need to desperately
run to retrieve their belongings
now would be the time so if that's not
the case then we can proceed so my name
is Mary Lu I'm a professor in the
Department of History and the program of
American Studies I'm also the head of
college for a Timothy Dwight College as
the head of Timothy Dwight College I
have the distinct honor of serving as
the custodian of the illustrious Chubb
fellowship established in 1941 out of a
prior large donation for education
purposes this was made in 1936 by Hendon
Chubb a graduate of the Yale class of
1895 since establishment the Chubb fund
has hereto the goals of providing
encouragement and aid to students
interested in government and American
public affairs the fellowship initially
aimed to foster among Yale
undergraduates an interest in public
service in local and
Affairs and then grew over the years to
include numerous distinguished visitors
in national and international affairs as
well as leaders in the world of the arts
and humanities since the 1940s the Chubb
fellows lecture series has inspired
generations of Yale students to
undertake public service and pursue
leadership roles in the hopes of
creating a better world today and for
posterity the fellowship has hosted four
US presidents George W Bush Gerald Ford
Jim Jimmy Carter and Harry Truman in
recent years we've welcomed the wide
range of national and international
leaders including the artist faith
Ringgold environmental activist Bill
McKibben physician and humanitarian dr.
hawa Abdi former Secretary of
Transportation and Congressman Norman
Mineta songwriter and musician possible
yang has taught in Hamlin University's
MFA program in writing for children and
young adults today I'm delighted to
celebrate his many achievements as an
award-winning and pioneering graphic
novel novelist writer and educator so
please join me in welcoming gene Luen
yang to the podium
[Applause]
good afternoon everyone I can't tell you
how honored I am to be up here to be on
this campus thank you so much for
inviting me thank you for sharing your
time with me this afternoon
so the fancy title for this talk is the
power of comics for inclusivity and
equality what I'm really gonna be
talking about is why comics matter I
care about comics because that is what I
do for a living I am a cartoonist I
write and draw comics too graphic novels
I've been doing this for about 20 years
now not only have I gotten to work on
these books I've also gotten to work in
universes created by other people so
about six years ago I got involved with
these books right here how many of you
have ever seen this show called avatar
last airbender almost everybody that's
great now if you haven't seen this show
if you didn't raise your hand you should
feel a little bit ashamed because this
is an amazing amazing cartoon I think
it's probably the best animated series
that America has ever produced it ran on
Nickelodeon from 2005 to 2008 and after
it went off the air Nickelodeon decided
to continue the story as a series of
graphic novels I was hired to write
those graphic novels for them I did the
first five volumes this gig was amazing
I think the best part of writing this
book or these books was that I got to
call Mike DiMartino and Bryan Konietzko
the two animators who created the
original series and they totally called
me back it was awesome I was like we
were BFFs about three years ago I
started working for DC Comics the
publishers of Superman Batman and Wonder
Woman I did a 10 issue run on their
monthly Superman series and then after
that I started having these talks with
them about what I might be doing next
they were the ones that brought this
idea to me they said gene how would you
feel about creating a Chinese Superman
for us and when they brought that up to
me I said that sounds like a terrible
idea I want nothing to do with it I was
kind of freaked out about it I am the
son of two immigrants my mom was
actually born in mainland China and her
family
just as the communist party was coming
into power
my grandfather her father worked for the
Nationalist Party that was the political
party that was in power before the
Communists so I grew up with some really
intense views about politics in China it
took to until I got into my adult years
to realize that things were a lot more
nuanced than I was led to believe
especially in modern China even so I
just thought man Superman is supposed to
stand for truth justice in the American
Way I didn't know what that would look
like in modern China so I said no I got
called into the office of DC Comics they
now have an office at Burbank you go
into the lobby they have giant statues
of Superman Batman and Wonder Woman
wearing their costumes from that Justice
League movie that just came out I got
called into the office of Jim Lee Jim
Lia is a Korean American he is the chief
creative officer of DC Comics he first
got into the comic-book industry in the
late 80s early 90s as an artist for
Marvel he used to draw x-men for them I
collected Jimmy's x-men comics too when
I was in high school a whole box of them
I'm a huge Jim Lee fan she called me in
his office and he says gene this Chinese
Superman idea was actually my idea I
wanted an Asian member of the Superman
family and then he said all the side of
the stuff I was in that office for like
an hour and I was just staring at him
thinking I'm sitting in front of Jim Lee
so at the end of that meeting I said I
guess we're doing this and we did we did
24 issues of new Superman it was a lot
more fun than I thought it was gonna be
and it's all about a brand new character
in the DC Universe his name is Kenan
Kong
he's a 17 year old kid living in
Shanghai who inherits some of Clark
Kent's powers to become the new Superman
the Superman of China now this worked
for DC that I did was definitely not my
first foray into the superhero genre
that would be this right here the shadow
hero is a book that I did with my friend
Sonny Liu a few years ago I want to tell
you more about this book towards the end
of this presentation
but first I want to tell you more about
me now I am an Asian American cartoonist
I'd like to tell you how I became each
of these things how I became an
asian-american
how I became a cartoonist and then how
these two spheres of my life
Asian America and the world of American
comics how they overlap so I became in
Asian America Asian American by being
born I was born here in America to
immigrant parents I've told you that my
mom was born in mainland China my dad
was born in Taiwan they both came to the
United States for graduate school they
met fell in love got married and had me
this right here is probably the cutest
picture of me ever taken I was about
three years old was a little bit
downhill after this but I grew up in a
house full of stories when I was growing
up one of the primary ways that my
parents and I interacted with each other
was through storytelling both of my
parents loved telling stories and they
mostly told me stories from China from
Taiwan I think this is true of a lot of
immigrant parents they'll tell you
stories they'll tell their children's
stories from the culture that they left
as a way of keeping that connection
alive my mom's parents were living in
Asia when I was growing up so she asked
them to send over a whole bunch of
Chinese language story books and she
would read these books to me at bedtime
as an adult when I look back on these
stories that I heard as a kid I realized
how different they are from most of the
stories that most kids in America hear
here's an example this is an actual
story book that my mom used to read to
me when I was like six years old can you
see what's going on there is a young
woman a mother who is breastfeeding her
own mom her own mom has gotten so old
that she's lost all of her teeth she
can't eat any solid food so she's slowly
starving to death and this young woman
is breastfeeding her own mother while
her toddler is crying in the corner
because he's hungry this was a
collection of short stories aimed at
little kids all about filial piety about
respecting and caring for your parents
I'm pretty sure if you go to the local
Barnes & Noble you will not find an
English translation of this book now of
all of my mom's stories my favorite were
about the Monkey King The Monkey King is
an old old Chinese legendary figure and
a lot about him appeal to me when I was
a kid first he's a monkey and I loved
monkeys I thought they were so hilarious
and second he knew kung fu he knows kung
fu he's a kung fu fighting monkey how
awesome is that he also has super powers
like an American superhero he can call a
cloud down from the sky ride it around
like a skateboard he can grow and shrink
with the slightest thought he could
change his shape anytime he wants and my
favorite thing about him when I was a
kid he has this this magic stick that he
beats people with so the stick just like
him he can grow and shrink just by him
thinking about it and normally he keeps
it the size of a toothpick tucked behind
his ear whenever he needs to fight he'll
pull it out or grow into a staff he'll
beat down some demon with it and he's
done he'll shrink it back down and tuck
it back behind his ear when I was a kid
I thought The Monkey King was so cool he
was the coolest my mom would sometimes
ask me a bedtime honey would you like to
hear about The Monkey King would you
like to hear about that young lady who
breastfeeds her own mom and I would
always choose the Monkey King so I grew
up with stories I also grew up drawing
my mom tells me that I started drawing
when I was 2 years old and I basically
never stopped naturally when he takes
stories and drawing in the add them
together you get animation I remember
being a kid and watching animated movies
at the theater or animated television
shows on my on my television at home
it was the first time I realized I could
tell stories by drawing and I was
fascinated by that in fact when I was
really little in early elementary school
my lifelong dream was to work for this
guy right here I really wanted to be a
Disney animator I remember in third
grade our teacher made us do these
biography reports we had to choose a
famous person and write about them I
chose Walt Disney and after that I
became obsessed with him I went to the
library I checked out as many books
about Walt Disney's life as I could find
I remember practicing for hours drawing
in that classic Disney style
I remember looking up an encyclopedia
for kids and encyclopedias like
Wikipedia
except it's on paper so I remember
looking up an encyclopedia when the date
of Walt Disney's death was because I was
hoping that it would match my birthday
because that would mean that I might be
his reincarnation that didn't work out I
even went to our local mall and our
local mall there was this poster store
and I special-ordered
a poster sized head shot of Walt Disney
not any of the Disney characters Walt
Disney's head and when that poster came
in I brought it home I put it up on my
bedroom wall my friends would come over
and they asked why do you have this
picture of a creepy old man in their
bedroom and I'd have to tell him that's
not just any creepy old man that is Walt
Disney
so I desperately wanted to be a Disney
animator this changed in fifth grade in
fifth grade one night my mom took me to
our local bookstore and back when I was
a kid every local book store had what
was called a spinner rack this was a
wireframe rack
they usually stick it in the corner of a
store it would carry a month's worth of
comics you could spin the whole thing so
you could see all those comics my mom
bought this issue of DC Comics presents
for me off of that spinner rack this was
a Superman comic it tells the tale of
Superman teaming up with these other
heroes who call themselves the atomic
Knights essentially they wear medieval
style armor and ride around on these
giant mutated Dalmatians to fight crime
this comic book blew my mind I loved it
this comic book turned me into a comic
book fan so I started buying comics and
I have to tell you even though the very
first comic book in my collection was a
DC comic I very quickly became a Marvel
fan you all know that here in America we
have two major comic book superhero
comic book publishers Marvel and DC for
some reason when I was a kid I just
thought Marvel was cooler than DC DC had
like this dorky vibe to them I remember
finding out in the DC Universe that
there was this character named Aqualad
and I thought aqua by itself is dumb
when you add the word lad to it that is
just the dorkiest soup
hero name ever so my childhood
comic-book collection was mostly Marvel
Comics pretty soon after becoming a
comic book fan I became a comic book
creator and this is actually one of my
favorite things about the comic book
medium that dividing line between who is
a reader and who is the creator it is
super easy to cross all you need are
some pencils some paper a healthy
ignorant of your own artistic
limitations you just make a comic and
there you go that's exactly what I did
my best friend in fifth grade was this
kid named Jeremy Kyoshi he was half
Jewish half Japanese
we started making comic books together
at lunch when our more athletic friends
were playing tetherball we would sit at
the lunch tables and come up with
stories then I would do all the pencils
he would do all the inks we'd give her
originals to his mom who would take him
to work with her wait till all of her
co-workers went home and sneak
photocopies for us we took these
photocopies we staple him by hand we
sold them to our friends for 50 cents a
piece we made eight dollars I was
amazing
that was the beginning of my comic book
career now Jeremy has since given up on
comics he no longer reads comics or
makes comics or collects comics he's now
a doctor he's a radiologist he makes a
lot of money he lives in this giant
beautiful house in Hawaii which is
really good for him but I kept making
comics I kept making comics through the
5th grade through the 6th grade I made
comics all the way into the seventh
grade now in seventh grade I had this
one friend who was just better than me
he was better than me in every way one
human being can be better than another
he was smarter than me he had better
grades than me he was better-looking
than me he was more athletic than me he
was better spoken than me I hung out
with a small group of boys in seventh
grade most of us couldn't even get one
girlfriend and this guy had six in a row
that's how awesome he was one of them
was an 8th grader he was a 7th grader
who could date an eighth grader that's
how awesome he was so one day he sees me
reading comics and he says gene if you
keep reading those things you will never
get a girlfriend if there was one thing
I was sure of in seventh grade it was
that I wanted a girlfriend so I listened
to him I stopped buying comics and I
took all the money that I would have
spent on
my books and I bought this instead so in
the 80s if you wanted to be awesome this
is the way you would do it you'll buy a
denim jacket you put it on go back to
school and silently proclaim your own
awesomeness so that's what I did I
bought a denim jacket with all that
comic-book money I went back to school
and I waited for the ladies to come so I
waited through the seventh grade through
the eighth grade through the ninth grade
and then in tenth grade I just had to
face facts I looked myself in the mirror
and I was like Jean this girlfriend
thing is not gonna happen for you and
there I was I had no girlfriend and no
comic books and I was like man I can do
something about one of these things so I
started buying comic books again here
are some of my favorite comic books when
I was in high school I loved the Hulk I
also loved this comic book called the
spirit it was actually a reprint of an
old comic strip from the 1940s it's done
by a guy named Will Eisner who's largely
considered the Godfather of American
comics the top honor in the American
comic book industry is called the Eisner
Award it is named after Will Eisner
that's what a big deal he is and I also
loved Uncle Scrooge when I was 16 I know
most Uncle Scrooge fans are like 5 I
love them when I was a teenager its
daily in case you were wondering I got
my first girlfriend about a year after I
started buying comic books again so my
friend was totally wrong you can
completely be a nerd and also find love
nerdiness and romance can be compatible
you know around this time in junior high
in high school this was also when I
started feeling this tension between
these two halves of myself between these
two cultures that I felt like I was
living in I felt this tension between
being Asian and being an American I felt
this tension between East and West this
is something that I talked about in my
2006 book American born Chinese in that
book I have this character his name is
Timmy he's the character with the brown
hair and these two panels and a lot of
the most culturally inappropriate things
that are said in the book are said by
this character Timmy Timmy is based on
these kids I knew when I was in junior
high we had this group of boys at my
junior high I'm sure you did not have
these folks wherever you grew up but at
my junior high there was this group of
boys that we used to call the stoners
they would wear heavy-metal t-shirts
they had ripped jeans there are rumors
that they did these terrible things in
the back parking lot after school
whenever this group of stoners and my
group of friends were mostly
asian-american boys whenever we passed
each other in the halls they would
almost always yell something racist at
us so I took a lot of the words that I
heard in the hallways of my junior high
and I put them in my book American born
Chinese now they certainly were not the
only bullies on campus me and my friends
we were also bullies there are actually
two groups of asian-american boys at my
junior high my friends and I were mostly
born in the United States we spoke
English without accents we would wear
American clothing we watched American
movies we listened to American music and
then there was this other group of Asian
American boys who came when they were
much older they came in fourth or fifth
or sixth grade they spoke English with
accents they talked to each other in
their native tongues they wore these
clothes that they bought in Taiwan with
misspelled English words on them they
would listen to Asian music watch Asian
movies and these two groups of boys we
have this weird frenemy relationship we
would say hi to them in the halls we
talked to them in class but and whenever
we were in a larger context we would
want to make sure that people understood
we were two separate groups we did not
want to be too closely associated with
them and then behind their backs we
would relentlessly make fun of them we
made fun of their accents we may find
other clothes
we called them fo B's fresh off the
boats I try to capture this frenemy
relationship between these groups of
boys at my junior high with the
relationship between Jin and Wei Chen
the two major characters in American
born Chinese junior high was when the
the probably the first time that I
realized that my cultural heritage that
the way I looked
made me different from the people around
me and the way I dealt with this in part
because I had internalized the words of
those stoners the way dealt with this
was to take that difference out
on this other group of kids that I
perceived as more different than I was
and this dynamic was actually reinforced
by the culture around me I am 45 most
Asian Americans my age have this weird
love-hate relationship with a movie
director named John Hughes you all heard
of John Hughes before so he's one of our
most celebrated movie directors he did
some really amazing movies he was behind
home alone and Ferris Bueller's Day Off
the reason why agent Americans my age
have this love-hate relationship the
love part comes from the fact that a lot
of his movies are really great they're
hilarious and heartwarming and funny but
then in one of his movies Sixteen
Candles there is this one character that
he introduces to the world his name is
long Duk dong he is a Chinese exchange
student he's played by a Japanese
American actor the actor can speak
perfect English but he invents this
crazy exaggerated accent for long Duk
dong we're never long Duk dong comes up
on the screen a gong goes off and in
that movie he is obsessed with gaining
an American girlfriend getting a white
girlfriend our friends our classmates
would go and watch sixteen Candles and
come back to school and start calling us
long Duk dong that's where the hate
comes from long Duk dong was such a
prominent part of my growing up that I
wanted to make some reference to him in
american-born Chinese so in America more
Chinese I have this character his name
is cousin Chinkee
he's essentially an embodiment of all
the negative Asian and Asian American
stereotypes that I could think of I gave
him that same obsession that long Duk
dong had of getting a white girlfriend
now after I graduated from high school I
went to UC Berkeley for college UC
Berkeley is a little bit like Yale
except that it is on the west coast and
it's a public school and it makes
immigrant parents maybe 15% less happy
than a Yale except they're still happy
there's just 15% less happy now at UC
Berkeley I felt like this tension that I
had between my two halves
began to resolve itself and it resolved
itself it began to resolve itself for
two different reasons one is the UC
Berkeley campus was and still is
incredibly diverse when I was there and
I think this is still true
no one ethnic group was over 50% of the
student population and that meant that
in that one campus I could be in one
setting and be a part of the majority
and another setting and be a part of the
minority the fact that I was switching
from one to the other on an almost daily
basis I felt like that grew my own
capacity for empathy including my
capacity for empathy for myself the
second thing was that at UC Berkeley I
realized that America is not America
does not have a single monolithic
culture America is actually a collection
of subcultures and I would argue that
the nation was designed to be that from
the beginning America was not ever a
melting pot we were not ever meant to be
a melting pot we were meant to be a
salad bowl this was an idea from Ronald
Takaki a professor at UC Berkeley in
Asian America the the subculture that I
was a part of was a part of that salad
bowl after graduating from UC Berkeley
with a degree in computer science and a
minor and creative writing I began
self-publishing my own comic books this
is the very first comic that I did as an
adult it's called Gordon Yamamoto and
the king of the geeks it's about a young
man who gets a spaceship stuck deep
inside his nose and it becomes friends
with the alien that's living inside the
ship it's loosely based on my own life I
kept publishing and publishing
eventually I signed with a few companies
and in 2006 American born Chinese came
out this was my very first full-color
graphic novel and I have to tell you the
support for this book was well beyond
anything I imagined
librarians and teachers comic book fans
bookstore owners all came out to support
this book and their support completely
changed my life they paved the way for
me to become the full
I'm cartoonist that I am today and I am
incredibly incredibly grateful for that
so that is how I became an
asian-american cartoonist
let me tell you how these two worlds
overlap now I don't have firm statistics
to back this up but it seems to me that
asian-americans are better represented
in American comics than in any other
American storytelling medium there are
just a lot of us working in comics
there's Linda Barry she's half Filipino
so I'm claiming her
there's Gregg Pok who writes for both
Marvel and DC Jay Lee draws for both
Marvel and DC Debbie Huey does this
amazing book called bumper boy there are
just a lot of us in American comics a
lot the last guy who came up on the
screen he's Jim Lee who I talked about
at the beginning of this talk he is the
chief creative officer for DC Comics and
I told you he began his career drawing
for Marvel so he began his career as a
fan favorite artist he was a phenomenon
I remember going to local comic book
conventions as a high school kid and
lining up for his autograph those lines
would sometimes be hours long he's a big
deal and now he's a big deal on the
business side I would argue because he
is both on the art side and the business
side of American comics that Jim Lee a
korean-american an asian-american might
be the most powerful person in American
comics so how did this happen how did an
asian-american be the most become the
most powerful person in American comics
the parents of Asian Americans
everywhere are asking how could this
happen
because working in comics is not one of
the approved career paths right it is
not doctor or lawyer or engineer and
this question of why there's so many
asian-americans in American comics
becomes even more perplexing when you
look at the history of how Asians and
Asian Americans have been depicted in
American comics here's an example this
is a political cartoon from the late
1800s during that time America was
seeing this huge influx of Chinese
immigrant workers and many Americans not
all by any means but many Americans were
worried about how all these immigrants
were gonna affect American culture
so pressure began to build on Congress
to do something and newspapers all over
America began publishing images like
this these images were meant to
dehumanize these immigrants so that
Congress would be willing to act and
they did in 1882 they passed the Chinese
Exclusion Act which effectively ended
all legal immigration from China in the
United States for decades this sort of
image was not just limited to early
American political cartoons it was also
found in early American comic books now
the one of the companies that I work for
DC Comics the DC those two letters they
got that from Detective Comics which is
the longest-running monthly title so
really the name DC Comics for the
company doesn't make any sense
it actually stands for Detective Comics
comics makes no sense Detective Comics
is incredibly important to the history
of American comics because that is where
Batman debuted this right here is the
very first appearance of Batman but
neither the series Detective Comics nor
the Company DC Comics began with Batman
Batman didn't show up until the temptu
Comics number 27
DC Comics the company didn't even begin
with Superman who debuted a year before
Batman in Action Comics number one DC
Comics introduced themselves to the
world with this this is Detective Comics
number one the lead character in the
lead feature of this comic his name is
chin lung and he is what we would now
call a Yellow Peril villain he is a
character who was designed to play on
the fears that Americans had of the
Chinese of the time for entertainment
value early American comics are rife
with these American peril villains this
guy is probably the most egregious his
name is egg foo he's literally a
man-sized yellow egg
just like chin lung he is a Chinese
super genius bent on taking over the
Western world a character designed to
play on the fears that Americans had of
the Chinese and believe it or not egg
foo is actually still in modern DC
Comics this is what he looked like looks
like nowadays now to be fair every now
and then even in the early days of
American comics Asian or Asian American
heroes were introduced we weren't always
villainized but even when we jumped to
the side of good there were problems
with the ways we were predicted depicted
here's an example during world war 2 DC
Comics introduced a team of superhero
pilots they called themselves the Black
Hawks the Black Hawks fought for the
Allies so there was one Black Hawk
member for every allied nation and they
all wore these snazzy blue uniforms
except for the black hawk from China the
black hawk from China looked like this
his name was general chop-chop he even
had this crazy catchphrase that he would
say whenever he got really really mad he
would say chop chop been double clust
crossed with an L all these examples
that I've shown you so far are from DC
Comics and they're easy to pick on
because they are our oldest comic book
company but Marvel also has their share
of Yellow Peril villains the most
prominent of which is probably this guy
right here his name is the Mandarin he
is the arch-nemesis of Iron Man and he
is essentially foo Manchu with 10 magic
rings I have to tell you I'm a comic
book nerd and as a comic book nerd I do
like reading old American comic books
even when there's stuff in there that's
kind of rough one day when I was reading
through old comics I came across a
character that I feel is well ahead of
his time this character might be the
very first Asian American comic book
character his name is foo Chang
he is an international detective and he
was a backup feature in a series called
pep comics pep comics lead feature was a
guy called the shield he's a patriotic
hero in the mould of Captain America but
he
does predate Captain America some people
think that Captain America is actually a
ripoff of the shield crab comics was
published by a company called MLJ
publishing who are still around nowadays
they call themselves Archie comics now
food chang-hee was not a superhero I
don't think he was the first Asian
American superhero but what he did have
was a magic chess set and the pieces of
this chess set would come to life they
turned into little people to help him
solve crime food chang is
quintessentially asian-american he's
asian-american before the term
asian-american was invented he was born
in China he came over the United States
for a university after graduating he
took up residence in a fictional
Chinatown
he wears western style clothing he
speaks English without an accent without
mixing up it's ours and his ELLs all
incredibly progressive for its time
unfortunately his arch nemesis is a
Yellow Peril villain his name is the
dragon and one of the starkest things
about these early fuu-chan comics is
they show just what a difference in skin
color and American education can make
the guy on the right went to American
University the guy on the left did not
in order for food chain to activate his
magic chess set he has to put on
traditional Chinese clothing and say an
incantation directly to the chess piece
here's the other thing what you wear
also affects your skin color like I said
despite all these problems I do think
that foo Cheng was well ahead of his
time he was not in my opinion the first
Asian American superhero that
distinction belongs to another character
I'll tell you about him at the end of
this presentation
now as the decades went on
representation did get better
during the 1970s American went through
this collective obsession with kung-fu
mostly because of Bruce Lee and American
comics were no accession to this
exception to this the the martial art
genre does calm
with its own set of stereotypes but I
believe compared to what came before
this was progress many of these martial
arts heroes were actually
three-dimensional they had
understandable human motivations they
had understandable human flaws the most
prominent character to come out of the
comic book character to come out of this
era was probably shang-chi the master of
Kung Fu who is essentially Marvel
Universe's the Marvel Universe's version
of Bruce Lee during this time we also
saw a character named yang of the house
of yang he is not important at all to
American comic book history I only
included him on the slide because I
liked his name now in the 80s this is my
childhood now in the 80s GI Joe
surprisingly was this bastion of
diversity there was a Joe member for
many many different culture groups here
in America and I always wondered why
that was as an adult I discovered the
answer the reason why the Joe's was such
a diverse team was because of this guy
right here his name is larry Hama he is
a Japanese American he's also a
legendary comic book writer he wrote
many of those early GI Joe comics and GI
Joe cartoons
so because of him we have a character
named quick kick who is on the Joe side
he's a Japanese American he's a martial
arts master and he is so hardcore that
he never wears shoes even when the Joe's
are fighting in the snow that's awesome
on the Cobra side there was storm shadow
who out of all the villains in the
franchise has the most complex and
nuanced backstory larry Hama
incidentally is also the reason why
Marvel Comics stopped coloring their
Asian Asian American characters that
bright yellow I got the play I had the
privilege of hanging out with him in New
York a few years ago we did this panel
together and afterwards we got a meal
and he told me this story he said that
in the 80s when he was working for
Marvel back then
Marvel Comics had an actual physical
coloring department in their building
nowadays if your color is working for
Marvel you do all your work at home on
Photoshop and then just email
work in but back then they had an actual
physical covering Department and one day
Larry goes into the Marvel offices he
visits the coloring department and he
just straight up asked them why do we
color our Asian and Asian American
characters this bright yellow that is
not an actual human skin color and they
said I don't know we just always done
that and they said maybe we should stop
and they did in the 90s x-men had this
very popular TV cartoon the x-men just
like GI Joe has always been this bastion
of diversity and representation of
Asians and Asian Americans has always
been strong with this team of mutants
there's Sunfire a Japanese mutant with
the power to shoot fireballs out of his
hands there is Jubilee an Asian American
mutant who feels like somebody I grew up
with she grew up in Southern California
and she has the power to shoot fireworks
out of her hands and there's also
Psylocke now psylocke technically was
born british but in one storyline she
was kidnapped by ninjas and given an
Asian body so I'm claiming her as one of
us representation did get better and
continues to get better to this day but
it still doesn't answer the question of
why why are there so many Asians and
Asian Americans working in American
comics this is something I like to talk
about with my cartoonist friends usually
after a comic-book convention usually
over a couple of years I'd like to share
with you two of my theories as to why
this is one for each beer that I have so
the first theory is this it's a theory
from the very structure of the comics
medium comics by their nature is a
combination of words and pictures if you
look at traditional Western culture
traditional European culture words and
pictures have always been seen as two
separate disciplines the people who are
really good at words were not the same
as the people who are really good at
pictures I actually think that this
dynamic of separating these two art
forms dates back to the Reformation it's
because of the Reformation in any case
whenever in the West
whenever words and pictures did come
together the results were seen as vulgar
or childish or immature if you look at
traditional Eastern cultures this divide
between words and pictures did not exist
it didn't exist not just in the way
Eastern cultures write but also in the
way they draw in paint if you look at
traditional Japanese printmaking
traditional Chinese brush painting the
image is almost always paired with words
with poetry and the work is not
considered complete unless both of those
elements are there the work is not
considered masterful unless both of
those elements are masterful so maybe
there's so many Asian Americans working
in American comics today because
something about our cultural heritage
prepares us for this combination of
words and pictures that's my first
theory my second theory is this it comes
from the origin of the comic book you
have to talk about this we have to go
back to my own origin as the child of
immigrants when I was a kid it was hard
for me to find stories with people who
look like me
both in the books that I was reading and
in the shows that I was watching back in
the day we didn't have an awesome show
like fresh off the boat so maybe I
gravitated towards superhero comics
because they were the closest thing that
I could find superhero comics comic
books in general as a publishing format
got their start in the 1930s 1933 to be
exact this many people believe is the
very first comic book ever within about
a decade when we got into the 40s comics
had become a mass medium selling
millions and millions of copies every
month a lot of the people that we now
consider the Masters of the medium are
children of immigrants specifically they
were the sons of Jewish immigrants from
Europe there was Jack Kirby who was born
Jacob Kurtzberg the co-creator of
Fantastic Four Avengers and the x-men
Joe Shuster and Jerry Siegel created
Superman together Stan Lee he was born
Stanley Lieber co-created Fantastic Four
x-men Avengers he also co-created
spider-man will Eisner I mentioned
earlier The Godfather of American
makes Bob Kane who was born Robert Kahn
and Bill Finger created Batman together
and Harvey Kurtzman founded Mad Magazine
all comic book legends all sons of
Jewish immigrants from Europe so from
the very beginning comics was an
outsider's medium it was a way for these
poor Jewish kids to find a voice for
themselves to get their stories out into
the world now I don't know if they meant
to do this on purpose I don't know if
they're consciously doing this but they
definitely embedded pieces of their own
experience into these stories that they
were telling I'll give you an example
Superman when Jerry Siegel and Joe
Shuster first created Superman in 1938
they established a genre Superman is one
of those few characters that is popular
enough and powerful enough to create his
own category of story and when they did
this they put pieces of their own
heritage into this comic that they were
creating Superman you all know his
origin story right as an infant he's
placed into a metal basket he's launched
into space to save him from doom he
grows up to become the savior of a
people this is essentially a science
fiction version of Moses story Moses as
an infant is placed into a basket of
reeds he's launched into space I'm sorry
into a river
different Bible launched into a river to
save him from doom grows up to become
the savior of the people Superman is a
hero with superhuman strength but he has
this critical weakness that's a sum of
all the strength in his case it's
kryptonite this mirrors another story
from the Hebrew Scriptures the story of
Samson a hero with superhuman strength
he also has a critical weakness that
saps him of all his strength in his case
it's haircuts now the central reality of
Superman's life is that he lives in
between two cultures most of the time
when most people see him walking down
the streets of Metropolis they think he
is a quote-unquote average American but
deep down inside he knows he's not deep
down inside he knows he's from another
place he's from another culture that
he's a foreigner and alien an immigrant
and just to get through his daily
activities he has to hide this fact from
the people around him this idea of
hiding who you truly are that was a
daily reality for Siegel and Shuster and
all their Jewish friends and family both
here in the United States and especially
in Europe
remember when Superman was getting
started in the 1930s so was World War 2
so this idea this dynamic of being in
between cultures have having two
different identities that felt very real
to me as an Asian American I had two
different identities I had a Chinese
name that I used at home at American
name that I used at school
I spoke two different languages Mandarin
at home in English at school I lived
under two different sets of cultural
expectations in fact there is so much
overlap between the Asian American
experience and Superman story that some
people have even argued Superman might
be an Asian American this is an argument
I stole from a friend of mine named Jeff
yang no relation even though we have the
same last name
ancient Yang's were just really good at
reproducing Jeff is one of the editors
of secret identities anthology of
stories about Asian American superheroes
by asian-american creators nowadays
though he's probably better known as the
father of this kid right here he's the
dad of one of the actors on fresh off
the boat so here's the argument I stole
from Jeff
that Superman might be an asian-american
I'm gonna lay out all the evidence for
you first he has black hair he wears
glasses his coworkers all think he's
kind of mild-mannered he has these two
different sets of clothes he has these
normal American clothes that he wears to
work every day and then he has colorful
foreign clothes that he pulls out for
special occasions he has two names in
American name Clark Kent his foreign
name kal-el has a hyphen in it
his parents are non-english speaking
scientists who send their kid to America
for a better life Superman is definitely
Jewish but he also might be
asian-american he might be like my
friend from fifth grade Jeremy he might
be an Asian American Jew you know
there's always been a lot of talk about
Superman versus Batman I have to ask you
all any Batman fans out there anyone
love Batman anyone like Batman more than
Superman okay there's a bunch of you now
I'm not judging you from up here I want
to make that clear I'm not judging you
I'm not telling you you're wrong I'm
just saying that for me when the choice
is between an asian-american Jew who
fights for justice and a billionaire
playboy who beats up on the mentally ill
I personally will always go with the
asian-american Jew so these superhero
books acted as my mirrors however
imperfectly they reflected parts of my
own experience back to me and they told
me that what I was going through was
important that I wasn't alone that other
people are experienced these same
emotional realities and I think that's
why as an asian-american I was drawn to
comic books I don't think I'm the only
one I think this might be another reason
why so many asian-americans are drawn to
American comics that were drawn by the
outsider leanness of the medium so
unfortunately for our parents I do think
this trend is going to continue as the
decades go on I do think more and more
Asian Americans more and more people
from outsider cultures are gonna enter
American comics and find their own
storytelling voice now let me tell you
about that character that I teased
earlier
the first asian-american superhero in my
opinion his name is the green turtle he
first debuted in 1945 in a series called
blazing comics and in a lot of ways he's
kind of a dorky character he was created
by Chu hang one of the first Chinese
Americans to be working in the American
comic book industry and he's kind of a
Batman rip off so he operates out of a
turtle cave he drives around in a turtle
plane he wears this turtle themed
costume he didn't even have a shirt
that's how dorky his costume is I read
about him and despite all the dorky
elements I was fascinated by this
character I was fascinated because there
is a rumor surrounding his creation the
rumor is that his creator Chu hing
wanted to make green turtle a
chinese-american just like he himself
was but his publishers wouldn't let him
do it his publishers were the small
company that's no longer with us they're
called rural home they didn't think that
a chinese-american superhero would be
able to sell in 1940's America so Chu
hing reacts the way all cartoonists
react when we were met with adversity he
gets really passive-aggressive and he
draws these early green turtle comics so
that you almost never see his face most
of the panels look like this all you see
is his turtle cape and then whenever he
is turned around something is obscuring
his face it's either a piece of
furniture or a character that's standing
in the way or his own arm and the rumor
is that chewing did this so that he and
his reader could imagine his character
as he originally intended as a
chinese-american I don't know if these
rumors are true but they're intriguing
enough to me that I wanted to do a book
about it so I teamed up with a friend of
mine named Sonny Liu and we created a
superhero origin for him the green
turtle only lasted five issues so true
he never gets around to confirming
whether or not he is a chinese-american
never gets around to telling us his even
his secret origin so Sonny and Liu and I
we created a secret origin for him it's
called the shadow hero and in our book
we firmly established him as a
chinese-american
I thought about why the green turtle
captured my imagination and and I think
it's this you know
asian-americans we often struggle with
this perception of Perpetual foreignness
no matter how long our families have
been here no matter whether or not we
were born here people still see us as
foreigners
I believe that superheroes are a
quintessentially American genre they
were invented here they became popular
as America was entering the world stage
I think superheroes at their best
express America at its best so when I
found out that in the earliest days of
the quintus this quintessentially
American genre there's this character
who might be a Chinese American I felt
this deep wave of affirmation I did
shadow hero out of that affirmation was
like American comic book history was
telling me there have always been people
like you here even if you had to hide
your face this is in part why I am proud
to be a part of a movement called we
need diverse books right now we are in a
sustained conversation about diversity
not just in American comics and books
but also in just American storytelling
in general throughout this presentation
I've been drawing on the work of dr.
Ruden Simms Bishop she teaches at the
Ohio State University and she wrote an
article called mirrors windows and
sliding glass doors that gave us a way
to talk about diversity in literature I
believe we need diverse books because
every reader needs books that are
mirrors and books that are windows books
that are mirrors reflect our own
experiences back to us and by doing that
they teach us to love ourselves books
that are windows give us glimpses of the
lives of people who at least on the
surface seem very different from us and
by doing that they teach us to love
others I believe that these two things
working in conjunction being able to
love other people the way we love
ourselves that is a foundation of a just
immoral society and that is why I am a
part of the reading without walls
program the way this program works is
you and your community
that a due date for yourselves and then
by the end of that due date you just
have to do one of three things one read
a book about a character who doesn't
look like you were live like you to read
a book about a topic that you don't know
much about or three read a book in a
format that you don't normally read for
fun if you really want to go for the
gold find one book that fits all three
criteria we've been running this program
for about three years now we've heard
from teachers librarians bookstore
owners who have told us that they've
been able to use this program to move
books that would otherwise not move and
that is everything that's that's what
we're going for if you want more
information please visit reading without
walls comm now let me end with this I
want to tell you that comics matter
comics matter because stories matter and
comics are a way of telling stories each
of us has this voice inside of our heads
that is constantly taking the events of
our lives and weaving them into a
narrative into a story this is how we as
human beings make meaning stories matter
how we are portrayed in the stories of
our culture matters because those
stories influence the narrative that's
inside of our heads they affect the
dreams and aspirations we allow
ourselves to have they affect which
risks we're willing to take stories also
influence how others see us they affect
how the people around us receive our
words our ideas and our humanity when
they look at us they see egg foo do they
see long Duk dong or do they see
three-dimensional human beings who knows
stories may even affect the likeability
scores we receive from the admissions
offices of certain Ivy League
institutions we all need more perfect
mirrors and we all need more perfect
windows so let's tell better stories
about ourselves and let's be willing to
listen to the stories of others because
stories matter thank you
[Applause]
thank you
now I think we have some time for
questions are there any questions I can
answer for any of you about anything yes
yeah thanks for that question so you're
obviously one of my people because we're
wearing a Green Lantern shirt here so
the question is whether whether there's
value to drudging up all old old
characters I I do think that now I do
think that now I think I think there are
two different ways of dealing with
stereotypes right one is to write around
them and the other way is to write
through them so I do think that there
you can't take a character like egg who
is egregious as he is and right through
him you know one of the things that DC
Comics allowed me to do chin lung the
the character on DC Comics number one
that I showed you all they allowed me to
bring him back so I brought him back in
a series and I and they allowed me to do
it in a way that was a little bit meta
so that I could talk about his origin
and and sort of his impact on Asians and
Asian Americans sort of thing so I think
you have to be careful but I do think
there's value in doing that yes
yeah good question do you have an answer
for that I love it oh okay okay
okay so so secret holders first of all
thank you for reading it see coders is a
is a middle grade series that I did with
a friend of mine named Mike Holmes or
six volumes out the sixth volume just
came out a few weeks ago and we're
trying to teach kids the fundamentals of
computer science while also telling them
an entertaining story so in that book
the main character is a young girl who's
named after probably the most important
coder in the history of computer science
a woman by the name of grace Murray
hopper and and you're also talking about
how you're kind of spoiling it that's
fine the the coders go into this
alternate dimension that is flat and in
that dimension women at the very bottom
of the social hierarchy and they're just
lines everybody else's shapes all the
men are shapes and they're just lines I
actually did not make that up so that's
actually from a science fiction classic
called called flatland
have you read flatland it's by it's by a
guy named Edwin Abbott and it's an
amazing book you all should be flattened
you could find a public domain version
of it somewhere right you can download
it for free on Kindle you can buy copies
of it like anywhere in any bookstore
will have it and it's it's a book about
it's a book about math it's a book about
religion it's a book about social
hierarchy and politics and it covers all
of it in such an amazing way but it also
it also talks about gender dynamics and
the the the commentary that I've read
said that if you look at Abbott's life
he was an advocate for girls education
when that was not a given and and people
read it as people read his his flatland
book and the fact that he made women
lines as a way of commenting on the
state of girls education during his time
right but but I don't know I don't know
I think
I think it's a rough book I think that
that aspect of the book is kind of rough
and I debated for a long time whether to
include that because they're add up
there are modern adaptations of flatland
where they just make all the women
shapes just like the men are you know
and I was thinking about doing that too
but then I thought I wanted to stay a
little bit more true to the source
material and I thought I could use the
hopper character as a way of pushing it
even a little bit further right
and I wrote maybe maybe maybe it didn't
work maybe it wasn't as successful I was
hoping it would be but that was the
thought yeah the thought was I decided
to stay true to the source material yes
yeah so so that's that's a question that
writers are constantly struggling with
you know is how do you make characters
more three-dimensional and more
interesting to the viewer one thing I do
is I like to base my characters off of
real people people that I know or people
that I read about I think I think that's
helpful and and second is I think as I'm
writing I try to be open to the
character revealing themselves more to
me on the page that doesn't always
happen but I try you know every now and
like writing is this thing where you
have to rely on the muse and the muse is
kind of a jerk sometimes
sometimes they don't show up and it's
just you know so so I so I think if I
set aside time regular time every day to
write and I write my characters with the
intention of listening to them when they
reveal themselves to me sooner or later
they do sooner or later they do yes
returning Superman did you go back to
China to do primary source research
there and also have you been back to
China with your parents and have you I
guess yeah so for Chinese Superman I was
not able to go back to China to do to do
research unfortunately I did work with
an artist
who was based out of Shanghai so I would
constantly be bouncing things off off of
him and then I also had a friend who's
lived in Shanghai that I would out ask
about but I didn't have first-person
experience which I wanted but I wasn't
able to swing it I have only been back
to China twice I went once when I was a
high school teacher we took a group of
12 students there it was kind of crazy
it was super funny but I was also kind
of crazy you know I had to say that
before I went I had a friend who's a
Spanish teacher who taught on the same
campus and she would do this every year
she would take a group of students to
Spain every year and she told me she
said Jean you got to make sure they
don't go out clubbing at night do
whatever you can to not go out clubbing
so we land in Beijing and the first
thing we do is we go to the square like
Tiananmen Square and we see these
soldiers marching in perfect formation
down the square never had a problem with
students wanting to sneak out they just
stayed in the hotel just like they were
supposed to the whole trip so that was
the first time they say the second time
I went as an author I did a school visit
at an international school in Shanghai
both of those times my parents did not
come with me I think going to going to
China was a really interesting
experience for me because I felt like I
was remembering things from her dream
like everything felt familiar but knew
like I should know what it is but I
don't you know like like I'd heard about
it through an echo that's what it felt
like the whole time yes
yeah I mean first I I do think that the
we can see evidence of the trend that I
was talking about just all around us in
the world of comics you know that I
would say that diversity among creators
is greater than it's ever been in the
American comic industry and it's great
it's great to see you know we are seeing
stories that are being published now
that would be unimaginable
just maybe five or ten years ago so one
of the biggest examples of this is from
Marvel Comics one of the most prominent
superheroes right now is MS Marvel who
is the first Muslim American superhero
to hold her own title and when that came
out nobody thought it would fly but it
totally did it was a huge hit so I think
it's great I think it's great I also
think that we do like barriers I would
say that I would say that every
generation creates barriers for the one
that comes after and we often are
unaware of what those barriers are until
we kind of get out of the way so I'm
sure that there are problems that we're
creating right now just from the way
that we're telling stories and there's
no way for us to see it until the next
generation comes out yes
yeah yeah I mean I think one of the
things that's great about comics is that
traditionally in America there have been
so few gatekeepers or there had been
ways around gatekeepers Comics has
always had a very strong tradition of
self-publishing you know I think in
traditional books you know in
traditional books self-publishing has
always had like a looser II or like you
tell somebody you're an author they go
Wow and then you tell them you're a
self-published author and they go oh but
in comics it's not like that
you know in comics many of our classics
are self-published so so I think that's
part of it that's part of it right
that's the outside earliness anybody can
establish a voice for themselves
in American comics if they want to now I
really do think that a lot of the divide
that we're experiencing comes from not
listening to each other's stories comes
from trying to boil people down into 140
characters
you know like human beings are complex
we think and act and feel in very
complex ways in order for you to really
understand human beings or a group of
human beings you have to be willing to
to spend a good amount of time with
their stories so I wonder again I don't
have the data to back this up but I
wonder if it does have something to do
with the decline of reading you know
when you read you are really spending
quality time with a text you're really
spending quality time with that author
and and that's I think that's part of
the solution is encouraging more quality
time with people's stories yes
yeah I mean I think I think there are
two ways in which graphic novels can fit
in the American education system one is
as an on-ramp to the discipline of
reading to the habit of reading and and
we've seen that right we've there's
stories anecdotal over and over again of
kids who don't like to read who begin to
read graphic novels and are eventually
introduced to the wider world of reading
the school library journal published a
study that found that the very presence
of graphic novels in a school library
ups the circulation of non graphic
material by almost 30 percent so the
kids might come for graphic novels but
they'll stay for the other stuff as well
so that's one way the second way I do
think is that graphic novels are medium
worthy of study in and of themselves in
the modern world what I think is that
graphic novels are a great way of
training especially young readers in the
skills of visual literacy I I do think
we have to be more critical about what
we see and reading graphic novels within
a classroom setting is a great way of
training kids to do that so it sounds
like we're out of time I want to thank
you all for being here really was a
pleasure and an honor to talk to you all
thank you
you